hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on Monster Hunter
rolled again instead we're gonna be
talking about this new event quest that
will give you lots of hunter ranks you
can get that HR 100 or wherever rank you
happen to want to reach as always I
covered the event quest for Monster
Hunter world as well as I have a ton of
solo guides on Monster Hunter world if
you guys are struggling with the higher
up monsters such as the Elder Dragons
and likelike Diablos narco ghonte vol
hazaki Oh stroke and many more so if you
are struggling with those monsters
definitely check out my recent videos
and with that guys let's get started so
the name of this quest is a nose for an
eye is a star 9 quest and it requires HR
30 to unlock this event quest there's a
little bit higher than most event quest
that we've seen recently usually these
are HR 12 to 13 this will requires you
actually put in a little bit of grinding
in bhr 30 in this quest you are tasked
with fighting a tempered Anjanette and a
tempered agile Rathalos and this quest
will give tons of HR once completed now
just in case you are unaware of how this
works since they are tempered they don't
have a different health bar what they do
about twice as much damage they do a lot
more damage the damage is increased like
I said because they are tempered and
their health is a little bit lowered
only for this specific event of course
because there is two monsters and the
more monsters you add in a quest the
lower their overall health pool is so
you're gonna be fighting a temper
tangent at and agile rathalos with a
little bit lower health and about twice
as much damage for some quick tips
though Anjanette is weakest to fire
while Auto Rathalos is weakest to dragon
and ice i recommend bringing flash pots
for ruthless when he goes in the air and
a fireproof mental for engine f as well
if you don't want to bring the fireproof
mental you might as well bring the
essentials of course as well with the
mega and max potions as well as life
powder if you're in a group I like to
rock the vitality mantle just in case I
get hit and as well as the rock steady
mantle so I don't get hit when they roar
so I can get that extra free bit of
damage but like I said this is entirely
up to you and whatever you want to do
once done you can go repeat this quest
or whether a group or solo however you
want to rock I'll show how much XP you
get on screen it doesn't look like a lot
but I was also 78 in three-quarters of
the way completed so about a third of my
of the HR that you got that you see on
screen is not there because that was
contributing from me hitting 78 to 79 so
once again you do get a lot of XP and
this is similar to the amount of XP you
will get in the snow and cherry blossoms
one
which was another quest they gave you
extended HR rank as well but that's
gonna be the end if you guys do enjoy
that definitely leave a like oh that has
helped me out subscribe for new I'm
covering these event quests every
Thursday whenever they come out and all
that good stuff to give to keep it guys
up to date on what event quests you
should be doing and how to do them the
best way possible as well like I've
previously stated I have solo guides for
the higher up monsters like the Elder
Dragons and other monsters that aren't
elder dragons but are also decently hard
to beat so if you're having trouble with
those you can always click on my
playlist as well my two most recent
videos are going to be on screen if you
guys want to check that out and with
that guys hope they have a great rest of
your day
and enjoy that event peace out guys